welcome back to CBS mornings we're fast
approaching the season of giving and
that means a season of hiring for retail
stores more than half a million
Americans typically look for extra work
at this time of year someone who knows
all about putting in work Nancy Chen is
here to tell us all about it Nancy good
morning hey good morning
slightly but in
but it boosts their holiday budgets
especially with those Rising costs we're
seeing inflation makes this holiday
buying and hiring season an unusual one
but there are plenty of opportunities to
be found
it's already the most wonderful time of
year that is to find work for the
holidays we're finding that people want
some extra money especially during the
holiday season after struggling to fill
shifts the past two years Jason Mabel
who heads East Coast operations for
clothing retailers Splendid kicked off
holiday hiring earlier than ever in
September this is the time where maybe a
teacher might have off during a few
weeks during the holiday season and they
want to come in and and pick up some
ships and with holiday costs expect it
to increase this Easier by six percent
people are looking for ways to keep up
given inflation and a looming possible
recession are there more people who are
coming off the sidelines to seek those
seasonal jobs it's definitely a driver
people are looking for cash and so those
bonuses and higher starting pay points
are very very attractive to them Julia
Pollock is the chief Economist for zip
recruiter and says even as the labor
market begins to cool it's still
sizzling companies are coming out with
big incentives including higher wages
Amazon just announced sign-on bonuses
going up to three thousand dollars with
potential opportunities for full-time
jobs this is a good time to be a job
Seeker this is the best job Seekers
Market Of All Times employers are still
having to make very attractive offers
and job Seekers is still in the driver's
seat but as consumers jump start holiday
shopping earlier to stretch their
budgets and plan to spend less than
usual major retailers are divided on how
they're hiring while Amazon and Target
are aiming for roughly the same holiday
hires as 2021 Walmart the nation's
largest retailer announced it's bringing
on only about a quarter of last year's
figure Macy's is also pulling back
taking on about half as many seasonal
workers as last year you can even see
around us right now all the people we're
seeing higher foot traffic people are
getting out there earlier and they're
also looking for jobs Danielle Devita
oversees about 80 shopping centers
Nationwide we met her in Paramus New
Jersey which sees the most retail sales
in the country but predicting hiring
targets can still be difficult you over
hire and then that cuts into your profit
margin you under hire and you don't have
enough people and people walk away how
difficult is it to get that fine line
just right this year it scales up based
on the fact that the expectation is
there may be more people in store so
that is the relative uptick there are a
lot of people out there who are looking
and returning to the workforce and
that's something that we're working to
facilitate
the hiring Blitz last year meant some
businesses started this season with a
higher head count than usual since a lot
of temp workers ended up staying on
still industry analysts say if you're
looking for a seasonal job now is the
time since it'll look a lot different
even a month from now I mean a lot of
these hiring sprees are happening as we
speak yeah and if you're looking for
that job get ready because the Holiday
Rush is for real we always wonder if
Americans will spend money during the
holidays and every single year we seem
to spend even more yeah it's got to be
hard to just try to figure out what's
the right thing to do nobody really are
people going to go back to the stores
they already are are they a lot of
people are spending the holidays with
their families in person this year too
so that also changes yeah no I'm already
noticing a difference and I like
shopping in person not just I do too
yeah I do too uh Nancy thank you very
much